然后你的目的是什么？
你的目的还想跟他过日子，
你就不要这么说说，
如果你的目的是想跟他过的话，
那么能保住房产归你，
能保住现有的存款，
黄金归你就可以了。
至于说以后赚的钱怎么分的话，
如果你不写，
以后赚的钱也是两口子共有的，
如果你写了，
就有一种赶尽杀绝的感觉，
他每次想到我赚的每一分钱都已经变成了女方的财产的时候，
你想他是什么心情？
我老公呢，
她是能力比较一般，
但是很会给女人提供情绪价值，
我当初是因为这一点被他吸引，
然后跟他结婚生子的，
但是他从小被家庭打压比较多，
自信呢也不太够，
思想比较幼稚，
在结婚之后，
依靠我的扶持和鼓励，
我年前开始做生意，
表面上他是老板，
但是实际上我是决策者，
而且我是业务主力，
所以这么多年他也成长了很多，
也有他的优点，
对孩子也越来越好，
对我也很不错，
我个人呢是肤白貌美大长腿，
不是虚假的，
就是大家对我的客观评价，
自己本身呢也不爱乱玩，
平时单位家庭陪老公陪孩子啊，
基本上就这些，
没有什么不良嗜好，
而且为了给老公提供情绪价值，
会在夜晚孩子睡觉的时候陪他喝酒，
然后在X生活上不定期也会跟他共同尝试新鲜的，
避免审美疲劳，
也会经常装计费。
嗯，
您能懂吗？
让他觉得自。
也很强，
提高他的自信，
然后X生活很和谐，
感情也一直很好，
我觉得他对我好也就行了，
钱呢我可以扶持他，
我们俩一起挣，
身边的亲戚朋友同事都觉得我们很好，
觉得他是个非常好的老公，
我自己呢也觉得很幸福，
但是我确实有一点强势，
因为我们这么多年沟通，
他也没有表现出特别明显的反抗，
所以我们也就这么过着了。
我个人比较爱做主做决定，
我们结婚十多年了，
有两个男孩，
我的性格呢是原来是不会考虑太多他的情绪价值，
但是这么多年我也看甄嬛传，
知否学甄嬛，
学名兰学林情窗，
都学了一点，
用在工作和家庭中。
然后再说一下我们的经济，
我们经济做生意，
原先的老店收益是150个，
一年纯利润是90个，
6月份我们即将开一个新店，
这两天我发现他找了一个三姐，
我实在是想不通他为什么会就是找三姐，
我也想找，
想找一下我自身的原因，
哪里做的不够好，
家庭的情况，
我跟他结婚十年了，
刚结婚的时候，
老公呢是跟公公做生意，
拿到工程款呢，
公公也不给我老公，
后来老公就不跟公公做生意，
出来找工作，
做过几次房产销售，
包括装修这些，
然后我就让他一起来跟我做生意，
扶持他做，
公公呢，
强势也有钱，
时不时也会补贴，
但是补贴不多，
给小孩舍得花钱，
但是这么多年呢，
说实。
话，
花的也不是太多的，
跟他的经济实力是完全不能够匹配的，
家里的买菜买肉吃饭的这种钱都是公共承担的，
我有的时候也会哭穷示弱，
让公公去付一些不是太大的费用，
他也也愿意去，
结婚十年呢，
他给孩子花的费用在十万十个W以内，
我接受这样的情况，
也没有跟他们争吵过，
也没有去有过矛盾，
但是内心会有落差感和委屈。
我公公的情况我需要说一下嘛，
你想说可以说啊，
我公公呢，
是做工程的，
他外面估计有3000W以内的费用没有收回来，
但是这几年因为大环境不好，
就是政府方面没有给钱嘛，
然后他的两套房子都抵押掉了，
从前年开始，
公公陆陆续续跟我们建了50个W，
期间还过10个W，
经济状况很糟糕，
我父亲呢，
平时会补贴我们的生活，
给了很多个W，
所以我那天会有很大的落差感。
一个月之前呢，
我发现我老公出了个3，
那个三是我儿子同学的妈妈，
还有一个女儿，
之前经常来找我儿子玩，
3也约过我出去吃饭，
当时应该没有什么异常。
然后一个月前，
3约我一起带孩子去上同一个兴趣班的课，
然后第一次去的时候是我送的，
第二次去的时候是我老公去送的，
我们三个人都是认识的，
三个女儿跟我儿子是托班同学，
我老公说是第二次送孩子。
到我公公的生意那个，
3说他在国外有订单，
我老公想做他这个订单的生意，
所以就跟3聊天，
但是这个是他们私底下的事情，
我并不知道，
当时3是跟他说，
如果被你老婆发现，
就任你老婆打骂，
然后他也可以出我，
不再出现在我们面前，
不影响我们家庭。
但前几天我发现他出，
我跟他一起进电梯的时候，
我发现他在聊天，
聊天的那个界面跟微信的界面不一样，
所以我就拿他手机看了一下，
他很紧张，
我要看，
但他不让我看，
他求我不要看，
我就给他了。
我当时也没有过多的去查他的手机，
然后回家的时候我就问他，
我说他跟3到底是什么情况，
他说只有聊天，
没有实际接触，
只是聊出感情了。
我就问他你是不是出，
他说我只有情感上处，
没有身体上的处，
有没有实锤的证据，
我没有实锤的证据，
所有的他的记录，
行车记录仪都被他清干净了，
但是我跟他对话的这个过程，
我录音了，
他亲口承认的就是他可以记这个事实，
他是精神上还是肉体上都承认，
只承认精神上的，
以我们的经验来看啊，
如果只是精神上的，
就没必要说他就死不承认，
只是聊聊天，
还至于吗？
你因为我们的经验来判断哦，
因为我是一个很冷静的人，
然听我说完，
其实我就一个诉求，
我的目的也很简单，
我就想跟你聊一下，
我的录音也录下来之后，
我就出门了，
我没有接他电话，
我一直到晚上9点多才回家，
然后。
很狗血的事情，
跟我质问他完了之后我出门我就发现3的车停在我家楼栋旁边，
因为那天下雨，
我是打伞跟那个3擦肩而过，
他没有看到我，
但是我看到他了，
然后我等他狗知道是在我们视线范围之内，
我又回头悄悄的拍了一下他的车牌，
因为我想要回家质问我老公到底有没有见这个3，
然后呢，
我在外面思考了婚内财产应该怎么样去处理，
我当时我就猜想他中午的时候应该是把所有的记录都删掉了，
美团抖音，
微信支付支付宝都删掉了，
因为我晚上找他的时候，
我第一时间我就问他，
我说你车上的行车记录仪有没有删掉，
他说他没有删，
然后坐上车，
他说没有了，
只有今天了。
当时我就很生气，
但是整个发现的过程，
我没有跟他吵，
也没有跟他闹，
我很冷静，
就是问清楚情况，
我就是不停的有点流眼泪，
还把自己头发剪了几缕，
我就告诉他就是让他产生愧疚，
他我好跟他谈条件，
晚上回去的时候呢，
我就跟他说日子过不下去了，
我要跟他分开，
但是其实我真实目的不是要分开，
我是要逐步的跟他谈筹码，
因为我知道谈的条件是要求尚得终的，
我让他跟我说实话，
在我不断的推翻我问他的这个过程，
他都是在跟我说谎，
并且在这个过程当中，
有一天3让他下楼去看对面，
我老公就不愿意，
3就逼他说如果你不下来，
我就在楼下叫你的名字，
我说既然我什么都查不到，
我就认定你跟他所有的事情都。
错过了，
这就是事实，
并且我跟他说我不会再信任他，
因为我没有任何记录，
看到我也没查到任何东西，
那在我的脑海里面，
你就是跟他什么都做了，
然后还有一个情况是什么呢？
从我发现他有三姐之后，
他几乎一周有5天晚上都有两三个小时在楼下不回来，
我觉得很奇怪的是什么，
就是我们那个方面没有任何异常，
跟以往是一样的，
就在前几天，
那个三给我老公打电话，
意思就是我老公骗了他，
反正我老公继续联系嘛，
然后我老公呢，
就跟我说，
你能不能跟那个三说一下，
让他以后不要再联系我了啊，
在那个三给他打电话的时候，
还说了一句话，
就说分手了，
以后不要再联系了，
老婆查他查的很严，
其实我当时觉得很奇怪，
你不想跟他联系，
为什么要说老婆查你查的很严，
没有意义，
就在他发现他第二天，
我跟他查了所有的婚内财产公证给两个小孩，
他同意了，
但是后来我查他有给3花钱的记录，
然后我说我要去做婚内财产公证，
所有的财归我，
他同意了，
我们也去公证处了，
但是公证处说这些就是我们手里的存款，
不太好去公证，
因为存款有流动性，
然后首饰金和金条也不太好公证，
也是就是没有实名制的，
然后我连线的目的呢，
是为了能够保全所有的婚内财产，
因为我有两个小男孩，
我自己本身是国企的，
不太适合做公司的法人，
所以法人是由他承担的，
但是我又不打算跟他分开，
因为他还有价值，
因为。
一我要保证我婚内的财产和孩子的利益，
所以我就想问一下您这块我是想要怎么去更好的方法来把这个财产保全的，
然后财产这块我需要跟您说一下呢，
你跟我说一下财产嘛，
我先跟你解决一下存款和手饰金这方面的东西，
存款这个东西呢，
就直接都存到你的卡里，
你们夫妻之间只要签一个协议，
你的哪张卡里多少存款是你的个人财产，
这个就可以了，
不需要公证。
存款手印需要吗？
要签协议，
签字，
摁手印，
然后你的首饰金这些东西的话，
就是在谁手里，
然后你们夫妻之间签一个约定，
说这些东西多少克多少克的黄金，
每年你要买的多少克多少克的黄金，
多少多少克的黄金首饰是女方的个人财产，
签协议就可以，
只要在你手里就行，
不需要公证，
这俩都不需要公证，
就是黄金跟存款不需要公证，
不需要，
那我有一个分红型的保险，
是200个W，
这个在我名下可以签协，
也不需要公证这个合同，
这个保险的话，
也可以把那个保险合同的编号写清楚，
这个保险的利益包括现金价值都属于你的个人财产，
这个签协议就管用好。
然后还有就是房子这一块呢，
在谁名下，
在我的名下，
但是是婚内购入的房子，
这些是可以签协议，
也可以公证，
其实不公证，
只要你这个协议是找一个婚姻家事律师专业的律师签的，
也管用，
因为本来。
还就在你名下签协议约定归你，
这个在法律上是可以的，
因为我们就是即将开一个新的店嘛，
然后我们年收益这一块的话，
我也是想要就是去做一些措施的，
您这边有什么建议吗？
用你自己的爸妈的身份去注册去做，
我要用你老公的身份去注册去做，
但是这个很难去做的，
因为毕竟我没有想跟他分开，
真的这么去做的话，
可能也会能显了，
您觉得有没有更好的方法呢？
因为要父母的不太可能，
你一旦用他的身份去做，
他又自以为这个钱是他挣回来的，
那只会助长他的那种，
他觉得你看钱都是我赚的呀，
你管我管那么严干什么呢？
他只会助长他自以为是，
就有些人他就这样了，
他不会客观的分析自己的能力，
客观的分析自己的贡献，
他觉得都是他赚的钱，
他会自以为是，
那我这边只需要跟他签一个婚恋的协议，
找一个婚姻的律师帮我们去这个协议，
然后拍的手印就可以了，
黄金，
然后分红型保险，
房子，
定期存款，
公司收益这块都是可以去放在我名下的，
对吗？
公司的分红这一块的话，
可能会存在一点问题，
要看你这个公司从法律上来看，
有几个股东，
他一个股东啊，
独资公司，
对啊，
那应该是也可以，
因为是他独资的，
他所有的收益呢，
是进入我的。
呃，
账户这个也是可以操作的，
想好你的目的是什么，
你的目的还想跟他过日子，
你就不要这么说说，
如果你的目的是想跟他过的话，
那么能保住房产归你，
能保住现有的存款，
黄金归你就可以了。
至于说以后赚的钱怎么分的话，
如果你不写，
以后赚的钱也是两口子共有的，
如果你写了，
就有一种赶尽杀绝的感觉，
他每次想到我赚的每一分钱都已经变成了女方的财产的时候，
你想她是什么心情？
对，
我也是考虑到这一点。
举个例子，
换位思考，
如果是你，
你发现，
哦，
你在外面做生意，
你老公是公职人员，
他不能够有这个名义在外面做生意，
你在外面做生意的时候，
你一想到我签了协议，
所有的钱都得归我老公，
那么我接下来要干的事情是什么？
我就是在做一个口袋，
我就是在做一份其他的收入，
这样能保证这个钱不要全都进到我老公的口袋里面去，
这是人性啊，
人性就这样换你，
你也会这么干的，
你做这么赶尽杀绝的这样一个策略的话，
你只会让他想办法搞私房钱，
想办法自己在外面再干点别的不让你知道的事儿，
对，
因为我也是考虑到这一块，
但是因为我是两个小孩嘛，
我肯定要为孩子考虑的，
因为本身如果说我其实是不需要这份钱的，
我不想让这份钱流入到就是。
专一那边去，
所以我就是必须要做一些措施，
他自己也认可这样的事情，
因为他也害怕被杀猪惨，
我把我的顾虑的点讲给你听了，
至一决策权的话还是在你手上啊。
然后还有最后一个问题，
就是我们4月份准备购一辆新车，
您觉得我们这个新车还有买的必要吗？
车子买不买取决于家庭需不需要，
那如果说家庭，
比如说送孩子上学呀什么的，
这个需要的话，
该买还是得买，
如果说家庭本来就已经有了，
不需要的话，
只是为了面子，
只是为了他在外面和跟别人谈生意的话，
那我觉得现在未必要买这个车，
因为一旦我跟你说，
车就是男人最大的玩具，
一旦男人有了一辆几十万上百万的车了之后，
他不住，
他就想出去显摆一下，
摁不住，
他就想开出去在别的女人面前展示示一下自己的雄性魅力，
我直播间有没有经历过的，
经历过的，
扣1就本来两口子日子过得挺好的啊，
他非得是吧，
踮着脚尖买一个几十万的上百万的车，
他就摁不住，
就天天想开着车出去展示一下孔雀一样去展示一下自己的魅力，
摁不住它，
好的，
我懂您的意思了，
谢谢你，
那就这样啊，
来，
我突然想起了一个综艺，
一个男嘉宾开了一辆大概一两百万的一个车，
非得让其他已经先到的那些综艺的其他的嘉宾要帮他去拿东西，
这个这边没什么东西。
很拿去了之后，
其实就是想让别的嘉宾，
不管男嘉宾女嘉宾，
看一下他开的是一辆什么车，
但是其实他不知道的是，
在这些男女嘉宾当中，
有一个几千万级别的女网红，
就是静静的看着她表演的那个表情是这个意思，
不像我们这些老女人看到这个做派和手段的时候，
也是静静的看着你表演，
就那种感觉。
记得点赞关注哦。